[Music]
hey
support uh indeveloper if you can if you
want to
if you choose to play the games links in
the description all right
dream a game by justin
brown every night the same dream the
details may be different but the
narrative is familiar
endlessly i wander through impossible
terrain the object of my desire is
always in sight but forever outreach
countless iterations dull my senses and
a nightmare of
looping patterns i consume
but always i hunger under what
what are you hungry oh
is this your bed
[Music]
look comfortable um
oh you're not dead
okay
[Music]
a leather wallet okay
inventory hover pointer over the top of
the screen right click to inspect
all right folk how do i open open
ah okay oh good
a driver's license don't need this empty
wallet anymore well
why would you why would you throw it
away is that you is this your wallet
okay i guess we're done here sure are a
lot of bugs on the ground
guess i'll leave
locked yeah i guess i should have
expected that i don't know
don't know why i expected it to open
it's too sturdy to break but i can see
through the latch
see the latch through the jamb the latch
through the jamb maybe
wiggle i think i can wedge this card
into the jam
got it wow access menu to save
do i want to is this important
this is a good idea am i about to die
oh
oh yeah oh this is
great
oh yeah
hang on a second
hang on a second is this the pt hallway
this looks quite familiar a stuffed bear
with a distended
belly its eyes are sad a telephone with
a built-in message recorder
there's an old message saved
thank you for ordering from bun in the
oven custom crafts
we are a non-profit organization where
all proceeds are donated for the benefit
of fighting ovarian cancer
every bundle of joy surprise inside a
bun in the oven cuffed
custom crafts
all right an empty bottle of myth
pristone pills are scattered across the
table
there's also a bottle of hydrocodone
practically brand new
i took them all right empty beer bottles
influenza ovitbir
and coppa ale all right a bit too snooty
for a blue-collar town
all right i guess we're in a blue collar
town
hydrocodone acetaminophen potent
painkillers very addictive
i've known people who died from overdose
mixing with alcohol they just stopped
breathing
yeah it's a problem okay
what is something swinging over there
got nothing to say about that i could
try it
i don't like it nope i don't like it
what am i about to see
what is that
[Music]
okay sure what the hell was that
i'm gonna grab these scissors
surprisingly sure
great i'm gonna need that i something
was
might have been a coat rack post-it note
ron jenner morning show 8 o'clock lies
lies lies
all right no power the buttons don't
seem to work
well this is great
this is horrible this is horrible an
ashtray stuffed with cigarette butts
a fresh pack of my favorite brand don't
mind if i help myself
an empty picture frame something is
written on it a happy marriage split
apart each and the other's demon
unite the two to fill this hole and find
the date they said
i do i gotta find a wedding photo a
rolodex
this lid is stuck shut
well all right oh it's a coat rack
it really doesn't look like a coat rack
it looks like a bloody horrible mess
[Music]
can i help you beepers
a 12-24 hour clock i can set the
well i time
[Music]
i don't know a code it's 25 a.m
that's what time it is clock reset
itself it only accepts specific times
yeah sure it do yeah sure it do
sure it do this is creepy
they're literally unsettling
i wish that okay okay
let's take a look at this weird ass coat
a large overcoat
pockets are empty all right good
i didn't want to do it anyway
oh it's locked not
weird let me look at this cigarette will
help clear my head
i don't know about that
[Music]
i don't even know where he is
there's something special about that
radio 8 o'clock morning show huh
maybe i can conjure up some memories if
i get it working oh it's a clue
system that's clever
that's clever ah that is clever
fabric scissors sharp and heavy that is
clever all right let's explore the rest
of the place before i go
diving into the radio business
might loop but maybe not okay
so we're gonna look at the radio
oh eight o'clock i set the clock
to eight duh and then magically time
will reassert itself to be that time
in this game right
eight in the morning eight in the
morning
oh yeah the time is set to 8 am
[Music]
who's there who wants a face full of
fist
oh i bet it's the looping door i bet the
looping door has now gone
i bet i bet the looping doors i bet it's
open
always
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna leave that door open oh
yeah definitely gonna leave that door
open
oh yeah
what's going on with this radio
yeah good question
good morning this is ron jenner with the
8 am morning news tragedy strikes still
ridge west virginia
static was pronounced dead in her home
at 2 p.m saturday the coroner records
the cause of death as asphyxiation from
the
overdose of opioids local authorities
have ruled the death as accidental and
without foul play truly a tragedy for
him a beloved school teacher
static is survived by her husband static
who was admitted to mason university
hospital at 6 pm for treatment of a
self-inflicted gun wound
this news comes a week after the
discovery of a dismembered corpse buried
in sunderland woods officially
reopening an investigation into a series
of axe-based serial killings
can you believe this jesse all the kids
listening to true crime podcasts when
the real bleep is going down in the
boondocks
you're right ron some real the hills
have eyes bleep out there
better than that deliverance jesse any
hillbilly come after me saying squeal
like a pig is gonna get
a size 13 up they ass
next interview with static okay anything
else
okay no no thank you
a guttural roar fills me with intense
rage why
yeah rage rage is what i feel no not
that way
nerd all right that's it okay well that
was fun
glad i did that i'm gonna go now
it's on about two a.m and then six a.m
so i'm guessing i need to go to
two and then six oh good yeah okay let's
try
two let's try 2
am 2 in the am clock reset itself okay
let's try
six six in the poem
time is such a six point okay good great
glow
uh-huh
did you put something in that pocket
[Music]
a large overcoat
there's a gun in the pocket great
excellent stuff let me just take a
looky-loo glock 17 with a full magazine
perfect exactly what i was hoping for
hello listen to me you suck listen to me
you son of a [ __ ]
i made you i [ __ ] made you you dare
threaten me over some [ __ ] you
caused
if it weren't for me you'd still be in
whatever hell hole
silly you cried out out and getting
[ __ ] by a grand jury
i'm sorry we should discuss this like
men
sunderland woods usual spot yeah an hour
oh i remember hearing something about
the sunderland woods
great place lots of sunshine
very beautiful this time of year hey all
right
this is
oh okay stop right there
yeah okay
hands on your head keep them up well
yeah
they're they're up oh boy
i said stop god damn it i wasn't going
anywhere
hands against the wall now okay
stop resisting or i will shoot i'm doing
none of this
i'm doing nothing
[Music]
i thought that door was locked
okay well that's a problem uh number one
checking the curtain please
[Music]
oh good you close that up
we're gonna pretend like that never even
existed it's too dark to see
well hey
that's weird all right let's take take
two
ah all right done with that
oh take a look at myself hey what's up
uh-oh where did i go
where
[Music]
yeah sick
oh there's an axe now i'll take
well i don't want to
i i don't want to i'll take that
perfect
[Music]
all right glad we talked an axe with a
wooden handle dried blood and crusts the
axe head
it sure does that
i ca it does it definitely do let's
combine the action gun to an
axi gunny combo kind of like do wheel
that [ __ ]
all right i also have scissors does that
help me at all
no okay good how about i gun the bath
how about i
axe the bath how about i opioid the bath
okay how about i go out and face this
dude
well i locked it something is blocking
the door
[Music]
well i mean whoa
hot damn porn photo
all right
oh 1987. is this the bite of 80s
am i not supposed to leave oh turn the
lights out before you leave
right of course
is that really what it was i
love that i love that
oh no
oh shoot it shoot it
[Music]
shoot it okay all right yeah yeah okay
here we go blam
keeps falling out of the frame great
okay well uh now then i guess not now
later later later let's just go through
the door i guess
this is creepy they real like it's not
fast paced
but it is really creepy there's
something
very unsettling about all of this okay
it doesn't like
2 a.m what was it 3 a.m
wait i thought it was 2 a.m maybe i was
wrong about that all the pieces are
there
oh wait scissor the yep
yeah drugs oh
it's drugs oh it's drugs more pills
oh good oh great
misoprostol for cervical ripening
induction of labor and treatment of
gastro duodenal
damage induced by non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs
but why though well combine these with
the painkillers i guess
all right so we got that which is
good well i got all i needed time to
mosey and damn it was it like 2 p.m
oh it was 2p i thought it was 2 a.m
i thought
[Music]
i thought it was 2 a.m
i thought
what's up
are you in need of some cervical
ripening
you need
scissors
all right hey
oh no oh no
please please what
oh you do need some cervical ripening
need medicine
please what's wrong sick so sick
what are your symptoms broken heart
battered body
two things will let me rest one to dull
the pain one to silence the voice inside
of me
right i'll look around see what i can
find yeah i trust this
yeah yeah this is trustworthy
all right you want
miss soprostel do
you want miss presto thank you the voice
inside is finally silenced
we both understand the value of our
bodies the abuse that comes
blissful silence searing pain numb the
pain
oh just be careful with this i'm sure
yeah okay here you go
thank you something to numb the pain
this is the bullet that kills me but not
the smoking gun
thank you i feel at peace you are kind
traveler
kind kindness to you is assisting in
your destruction
kindness is aiding a stranger even when
it's inconvenient kindness is speaking
out against injustice even when you're a
victim
i'm a victim as much as you are my fate
was a choice and there is power in that
then why is this dream always the same
chasing a cycle of guilt and suffering
endless [ __ ] repetition
what is your role traveler
stillridge called and i answered yep
and here you are relieving the same
painful moments again and again
i hate nothing more than indecision i'm
not going to straddle the fence here
which puts you in incredible danger
you're a fool or a masochist
goodbye traveler until we meet again i
wish this was the final goodbye
for you it is for me you are not the
first tonight
you are not the last
well i'm confu i'm confused um
why did you [ __ ] yourself to death what
[Music]
happened
oh oh it's a photo i thought that was
your bowels losing
[Music]
all right okay
wow 21-12 80s 21
12 87. all right let's put them together
hey look at the happy couple
21 12 1987.
december 21st 1987
yeah we did it i feel great
guy i have a gun but i have a gun have a
gun
i've gone i have a gun
gun try me [ __ ]
who's there who are you who's there
ah rolodex with dated cards somehow
there are thousands of them
okay today i married the love of my life
my new partner is a young
buck from new york eager to learn and
the help brought the sparkle back to
this house
i'll let ben stay as a living handyman
the neighbors will talk but
[ __ ] them i'm doing the right thing few
years and i'll be
chief king of the [ __ ] castle
[Music]
freedom freed
dumb
[Music]
oh oh this is why i have a gun
i got squamped
i got smooshed now smash
me ah yeah
oh yeah man yeah that hurt should have
should have used the gun
oh wait okay but i have my step what is
happening i'll get you yet [ __ ]
you wanna go you wanna tussle with the
muscle
[Music]
come at me
oh
[Music]
now
i'm falling
or i'm flying okay
are we is this
[Music]
hi wakey wakey eggs and bakey coffee's
up
ah well where am i dee's diner best hub
for grub and all
still rich can i take your d nope john
boy harold manager just call me jb
that's what everyone calls me
i run this place best rest stop on
scenic 33
i actually made it to still ridge
started drifting as soon as i hit the
mass
nuttin that's a nun i should say you
came stumbling in ordered coffee and
breakfast and passed right out
must have had a nightmare you were
thrashing something fierce
been driving hard i'm not usually this
reckless glad to hear it friend
aims omar omar fletcher happy to have
you it's always nice to have another
brother in town feel me
if and you have any questions ask away i
know everything that comes and goes
around these parts
well uh was that just the
intro am i actually in still ridge yes
sir best little rest stop
on the 33. i entered a silverage before
and i've got family in williamson what
goes on around here
tourism this area is one of the more
secretive parts of the underground
railroad deep valleys tree cover and
plenty of rivers to hide from dogs
used to be shiny ancestral land a lot of
superstition around these parts
really what haints and mountain lights
got
people turned around here you know how
white folk be
first sign of goose pimples and they
look to the sky like
jesus about to pick him up from football
practice
of course when religion fails guns do
the talking
shaun he were long gone by the time this
town was settled but enough was left
behind the locals still
hold their breath when passing a mound
what about you omar what brings you here
i got a letter anonymous told me to come
to still ridge and wait for them
i know sounds like a scam but the letter
mentioned something only a few people in
my life would know
people i haven't seen in years am i
being foolish
doesn't matter if you learned something
from the effort questions are easy
finding the answer that's the part that
hurt something sinister happened in
still ridge
town history goes back to the war of
1812 omar
got to be more specific 1987 right here
and still ridge yeah but right here like
near this diner
yeah serial killer stalked the area
chopped people up with an axe barely
made local news
look up still origin wikipedia and it's
all red links
it's a local legend now kids will dare
each other to spend two minutes alone in
sunderland woods
tumac gonna get you they say two minute
axe killer my ass
[ __ ] no siri shut up tumac
all right this axe killer what was that
about i was in middle school back then
all i know is the prime suspects were
two high schoolers never caught him
manhunt resulted in a lot of false
arrests tampered evidence forced
testimony thrown out in court
local was shot dead police thought he
was a suspect but nah
wrong place wrong time wrong color
when i got that letter i tried my
damnedest to look up this place
all i could find was an unresolved
mysteries post by a kid in elkins from
did that ax killer ever get caught no
news no press relief
what the [ __ ] yeah same ammo a copycat
or coincidence nothing came from it
i doubt the suits in washington even
reached a foot to the mountains
reach the foot of the mountains if it
was a copycat it would have been a local
you said it yourself it barely made the
news elkins ain't even an hour drive
from here yet they called
it called it the ax killer while you
called it what was it
tumac who are you true crime author
journalist fed up with
gawker listicles celebrity podcaster
i'm a therapist i help people deal with
grief and trauma
and who are you here to help omar
fletcher i don't know
i tell you that's weird but you wouldn't
be talking to me if you thought i was
tripping
huh let's drop the subject please it's
hardly table talk
a lot of secrets in this town all right
but like i said questions are easy the
answers will get you killed
or killed by who drank my coffee then
i think i missed this is
damn good coffee excuse me thank you
this
diner here is my hobby but coffee
roaster is my profession
subscriptions are big money these days
and everybody's chasing a good cup
i like a good meal but i ain't a picky
eater in the navy days a tuna fish
sandwich and cup of joe were all i
needed
i'm aware of mid-rats how's it taste
clean city roast
chocolate and almonds you got a distinct
palette you ever tr
tired of whatever you could do i could
use a taste tester
huh my mom told me my bougie taste
wouldn't get me far
that would be yours one moment that
would be my what
oh my food ah okay
smells good uh what did i order my
rotating special this
is burgu venison mushrooms carrots
potatoes and wild herbs thickened with a
little cornmeal
i'm sure as hell hungry
no silverware for me thank you
well delicious
hold on thanks food is a universal
language you can learn a lot from its
ingredients
preparation rituals and flavor a forest
it was a forest and
something else someone else was there i
got you speaking in
tongues for sure cities are built with
bricks cultures built with calories the
wealthy heat slim meals while the slaves
lives off the trimmings
history of america right there history
of the world
burgu is a working man's meal communal
freshly hunted deer veggie source from
local farms and gardens everyone gives
what they can and receives what they
need
why did i see a vision of the forest
though that's a big question for 10
bucks of course you got to give it back
thanks for the meal let me pick up the
bill yeah oh let me get this one
this time the hell that photo
warning jb i'll have my usual
who the hell is there
oh there we go
i really like that i actually loved
the beginning experience of the actual
horror part of it
like there was a lot of exposition to
get through there but as an intro to the
game
i mean it was very pt don't get me wrong
it was it was clearly inspired
by pt but just the pacing
was something that i haven't seen in a
horror game in a long time
slow methodical take your time
really don't make people want to go
around the corner control the camera so
you can't see what's around it's like
it was well done looks simplistic but
obviously it's trying to emulate ps1
that really spooked me it was
it wasn't just scary it was fun right
and i haven't had fun playing a horror
game like that
in a long time because i played a lot of
scary games don't get me wrong
but that was fun okay
very cool stuff here i want to see this
be made to full to go support jb
those are very good that was very good
i was still rich thank you for stopping
by
my channel is always open for you to
enjoy
it
i'll be here though when you get back ah